call my agent
jaden pickett smith my man what up clyde
hey look man i'm gonna be real with you
okay this alien boy script
i'm not feeling it i mean it's hard
being will smith's son
i just want to make sure my next project
reflects that i'm a down-to-earth normal
kid
am i making any sense yeah yeah i'm
reading you loud clear i've got a script
right here very real called street ball
talk to me okay so you play tony
he's a kid from the streets lives in the
hood in a house with his mom
stop house
oh it's like a tiny mansion got it go on
so his mom and he uh they live in this
house and she works at a supermarket
ah oh uh a supermarket's like a mansion
uh but it's full of food and anyone can
go there so like where the butlers go
yeah basically so so he uh and wait you
said his mom was
doing something at the supermarket
working so
working is kind of like acting on a set
every day in a film that no one's ever
gonna see
and it lasts for the rest of your life
oh like a maid
yeah yeah she's like the maid of the
supermarket awesome continue
anyway tony doesn't make the basketball
team right so he decides to start
playing pickup games of street ball
outside
so he plays basketball on his plane
no on the ground in his limo
no uh outside is that stuff that goes by
when you're inside the limo
oh snap he plays basketball outside the
limo door
yeah yeah yeah yeah so then he gets
really good at basketball
and then blah blah blah blah fast
forward at the heart of the story tony
has to choose
between his mom
yeah choose is when you have to make a
decision between two things you want but
you
can have only one but
there's two yeah
but i mean he he can't have both
what'd i say about science fiction clyde
it's a no
okay we'll pass
dad bless you thanks
you